big thing final season which I still
can't believe after twelve seasons I
can't believe it's gonna go on forever
it has not hit me at at this point are
you guys just soaking up every last
moment together you know we really are
things that we maybe took for granted
over the past few years we're taking a
lot more seriously like our little
Huddle's behind before we come out for
their show and our curtain calls in the
audience and important little moments
for sure
I bet more than ever you guys are
keeping track of the days like the our
days are numbered right yes so now I'm
just so glad we have a whole season to
continue shooting so maybe that's why it
hasn't hit me yet but it will
so this last episode penny a lender
talked about kids how do you feel about
children they're okay I guess I mean I
saw one I wouldn't throw a rock at it
what why would you throw a rock there
child I mean what can we expect from
that I loved the episode I love that you
know sometimes it's just not in the
cards or you're not feeling it you're
not ready and I love the pennies working
and she was honest and you never know
what can happen I think you could never
say never but I like that they had an
honest conversation about it
what did please didn't have kids your
thoughts on kids align with pennies or
are they different I'm definitely I'm
not there yet not quite there yet but I
know that it will because I love kids
but you know I'm a worker bee right now
one of my career is my focus in my
husband but we love kids and we love
animals so we're we're men time children
yeah furry baby we're animal lovers yeah
I love it and finally you're gonna be
the voice of Harley Quinn that's
exciting
Parkside are you to join the DC Universe
I am thrilled I'm honored it's a great
iconic character and there's been a lot
of spins on it in the past so we're
hoping to bring a fun modern one and
it's fun to yell and scream
[Music]